concours du meilleur objet nous sommes
avec maxence hugo
il a gagné la gagner les règles sont des
règles mal à l'exprimer de maroun de
messieurs aujourd'hui vous avez ramené
deux objets oui ils sont bien trop il on
va refaire ce concept qu'on avait fait
deux fois avec maxence est simple donc
je compte en liga de vous avoir eu tous
les deux ça mais cgg grave c'est cool on
va à tour de rôle endossé l'aurait vu
justement saut en parachute c'est
psychologique père coalition va chacun
notre tour endosser le rôle du
commercial c'est à dire vous allez venir
avec votre jeu vous allez présenter et
vous allez devoir donner envie de fou
aux gens et aux jurés de l'acheter à la
fin de chaque prestation les deux autres
personnes dont une dame est une note
basée non pas sur cl objets style ou pas
mais sur l'ensemble la prestation les
fonctions de l'objet et comment ils ont
été présentés le charisme aussi de celui
qui est présent et à la fin de la vidéo
celui qu'on a obtenu la meilleure
moyenne générale gagne celui qui
commence on a regardé maxence alors
bonjour monsieur
o une assistante de zazie dante ça monte
en niveau à chaque fois vous existez je
vous ai ramené une bouteille d'alcool à
ses débuts jean fournier on va faire la
fête les garçons à robin hobb
voilà
vous êtes en soirée l'alcool voilà
consomme avec modération je rappelle et
là vous vous dites je me connais ce soir
il faut pas que je déconne et il faut
que je mette des piles dans cette
rubrique qui marche
c'est les piles rechargeables que j'ai
achetés sur ses crédits de charges et
donc vous êtes en soirée ou dit tiens ce
soir je lui balance un peu est-ce que
temps de changer les pays tout en
continuant la présentation crois mais je
comprends rien bon déjà et ouais
ouais messieurs veut surveiller ma
consommation d'alcool ah bah pourquoi
pas un décapsuleur quit heures
d'ouverture
regardez à il m'a mis deux
vous avez relevé le petits bruitages à
l'ouverture pas vos jeunes ont
[Musique]
annoncé le bruit le plus court de
l'histoire du bruit c'est un objet bonus
à 100 je suis pas venu vous présenter ça
c'est du bonus levé vous soulevez fait
une petite soirée pyjama
hop on est là on en soirée
[Musique]
ça pue la bien comme ça quand tu en vois
un mec j'ai trop drôle en soirée est-ce
qu'on peut s'asseoir pour poser une
petite série de questions j'ai besoin
des briques pas mal sa tenue tu l'as
déjà utilisé en soirée du coup non
attends mais tu l'appelles tu disais
ah non c'est bon peut-être je me trompe
mais je crois avoir vu vos vraies
intentions
c'est un véritable héros là à qui on a
affaire c'est à dire qu'il va aller voir
les gens qui n'ont pas la chance de se
rendre compte qu'ils ont déjà énormément
bu et qui peut être mise à prix en plus
et donc il va subtiliser leurs bières
faire rentrer cet engin de dans chaque
goutte qui tombe sur le sol est une
goutte en moins dans le corps donc le
but en fait de cette personne ait dû
lutter contre l'alcoolémie et pour ça
pour ça
en fait ça marche avec du gaz
franchement je n'ai pas forcément envie
d'en savoir plus long paquebot d'action
cette idée oui
et pas content si ça va à tâtons d'un
commun objectivement 19 ha ouais et du
coup ça ce qu'on peut l'acheter oui à
ces vendeurs sa demande
[Musique]
d'enquêté
mais si monsieur monsieur vous vous
souvenez il ya eu une révolution
industrielle à un moment donné iphone os
amis d'autres inventions un peu plus
vieille le feu la télévision entre les
deux entre le fait la cohésion il ya eu
là l'imprimante c'est exactement à
l'imprimante et bien laissez moi vous
présenter
le pistou les imprimeurs l'imprimante
portable
vous avez détourné moi des fois des
trous de mémoire genre eu mes clés je
les ai mis là j'en étais sûr genre
comment ça s'appelle déjà ça une porte
venez voir une si grosse machine passe
écoute
je peux faire sur notre corps j'ai pas
essayé j'ai peur que ça me brûle ah oui
alors peut-être pas
attendre une demi-heure de ce tee shirt
on en pense quoi je trouve qu'il manque
un truc
au règne baleine l'ong a redonné en
russie sénégal écrit les retrouva son
regard commence est ce que quelqu'un
peut l'essayer ok ce qu'il a écrit
merci à tous d'être venus j'espère que
ça vous a plu perso j'ai kiffé merci à
tous d'être venus j'espère que ça tourne
en boucle est ce que tu as institut
session plus crédible quant à l'éolien
déménager les cartons ok
avec séraphine c'est tellement ravie
mais montre avec ses pots cassés donc on
récapitule on peut marquer le nom des
objets sur les objets si vous apprenez
deuxième l'emportant en espagnol comme
on dit paul czm marque crochetage passe
devant j'intègre le mot papa faux fil
des jours hop deux semaines plus tard de
la barcelone milan mais c'était beaucoup
le tee shirt on peut l'améliorer on
marque ce qu'on veut il n'y a pas de
souci sa science à résiste à +10 lavage
et enfin quand on déménage pour les
cartons on gagne un temps fou voilà
c'est la fin de la présentation
merci d'avoir ces jeux vous l'utilisez
pour ta note bien sûr si nous laisse
écrire la note bien son jeu nous laisse
écrire la note de la nôtre milliards
bien sûr
[Musique]
ok vraiment peu tanger connaît un
algorithme away basé sur une entité
artificielle qui normalement va lire
dans vos pensées tiens ok basique
20 soit sur un frais ôta qui fasse moi
je suis trop content
vas-y à toi je peins sur 20 sur 20 en
tout cas je vous remercie du couple
n'ont rien de rien c'est un peu étonnant
il ya souvent une contradiction se
pensent avoir ressenti et est-ce qu'on a
réellement votre t-shirt j'habite là
j'ai prévu une note en dessous de deux
chiffres donc genre 3 par exemple et là
je suis à 20 tu as fait quand même
beaucoup grâce à toi j'ai eu un déclic
je pense qu'il ya un problème dans mon
cerner davantage de deux ans d'amour on
a fait moins un cadre gros franchement
merci donc on peut
en vrai maintenant qu'il est pas là tu
t'es régaler dit la vérité non non non
ouais il va nous faire un truc par
rapport aux actualités du jour c'est sûr
ça lui fait jouer j'espère que vous
allez bien
cette invention les amis ça a été le
fruit de long travail de recherches pour
essayer de rendre la vie des gens
meilleurs je suis venu là en mettrons
cpnt
excusez-moi égaux mais je veux dire j'ai
plein de boîtes en carton chez moi je
n'ai pas encore commencé à présenter un
pardon et je me suis dit comment rendre
les gens davantage heureux dans la vie
au quotidien des tartes région sera dans
les bonnes nouvelles très bientôt je
vous montrais pourquoi c'est un pendant
qu'il a senti ce panda
va vous faire beaucoup rire se ferait qu
il va vous faire beaucoup rire ce
manneken pis ça vous faire beaucoup rire
ce duo da va vous faire vous beaucoup
rire venez vous faire extrêmement rire
chaque matin on avait beaucoup rire
[Musique]
j'insère le dentifrice branche rec ça
doit faire mal ça pas mal mais c'est à
ce que je serai qui se retrouve
[Musique]
ses manies
alors le nez une particularité parce
qu'il est équipé de deux narines c'est
pour les couples exactement regarde ap
l'agent de l'argent voilà à plat les
rabat-joie dont je trouve ça bien que m
n'hésitez pas en tout cas ça marche bien
qu'identifié son général au quotidien je
sois signal fort voilà après où tu fais
tu fais un placement attention plus ça
va tomber ah oui mais tout va présenter
la brosse à dents tu veux t'en serai
mieux sorti je pense qu'ils me voulaient
que les gens soient heureux et
j'apprends par notre pétition te plaît
reste à ta place il est dur mais juste
peux-tu savoir ma note hugo oui salut
c'est hugo sur 20 maintenant il faut
qu'on montre qu on le convertit
spoliation avec au commerce et en
traduit moi ça lui c'est hugo sur 20
s'il te plaît avec la bonne association
toupin
à 15 sur 20 ans et pendant 15 / 20 à ce
qui fait treize années passées de 13
mois j'ai décidé de te mettre la note de
14 sur 20 c je trouve ça assez sympa si
j'avais des enfants je leur aurais pas
acheté à une mention spéciale pour le
shrek et qui est extraordinaire
j'ai pas vu un éclat de rire immenses
yeux vous quoi bon comment ça commence à
la 7 ans et leurs assistants bon il
maltraite un peu se désenclaver une
claque des doigts
je demandais de me faire une touche
juste beau gosse
ça va les gars
vous possédez un ordinateur
oui je sais que vous êtes débordé chacun
vous les actualités monsieur travers
bout de petites vidéos marrantes
intéressante rabaissons jeu ça fait
passer le temps la crbc je crois il vous
arrive parfois de manger je pense devant
votre ordinateur dont n'ont jamais vous
êtes un peu pressé up le matin vous
traîner sur twitter n'ont jamais il
arrive de laisser des miettes pour son
bureau ça nous arrive à tous
[Rires]
comment je vais faire pour nettoyer un
bal énoncé troc ou un aspirateur
il est ou encore celui-là faut je
démonte machins sont ils déjà sur des
zones où ils font des trucs sans fouet
qui aspire bien et s'il s'en va est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu un mini aspirante
c'est henry henry le mini esclatats
aucune chose que la bei est passé à huy
[Musique]
papa
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais alors voilà évidemment je sais
pas parfait malgré ce soit y évoluent
chaque miette mais grâce à mon petit
henry j'ai pu enlever tout tout s'est
alors c'est des clips sabaa
aux mains qui étaient autant la seconde
mais bon pourquoi ça craque quand tu
marches en jdg courbatures l'aja j'aime
beaucoup de sport
ont pris un rasoir depuis qu'elle est
visuellement
c'est un rasoir gagnant on te montre les
nôtres j'ai mis la note
j'ai mis la note elle vient de perdre un
point samaël m'a perturbé là donc j'ai
mis la note de onze sur vingt en disant
qu en gros ce serait un objet assez
lucide empêche le quotidien ouais ça
fait du bien gm est aspiré de vouloir
tout nettoyer la red je ne contrôle plus
taillé autonome
allez il s il voulait mettre vingt 120
euros - maxence c'est un 15 sur 20
j'ai trouvé henry très mignon qu'il ya
une vraie complicité entre tous les deux
mais un tout petit et m'a fait beaucoup
de bien sur si peu plus il ya vraiment
un truc qui me marque et c'est pour ta
tenue en fait je m'en suis toujours
parmi ces gens et j'avoue que je connais
à 11 ans tous super même s'il veut plus
c'est trop cool merci vraiment plaisir
[Applaudissements]
je suis me raser la tête aussi
[Musique]
les amis je suis terrifié que ce qui a
vous avez vu les agressions qu'augmente
la peur qui s'installe vraiment une
sécurité partout il faut qu'ils étaient
de les chaînes d'info liens non je me
garde ludo décrypte un gars a tué un
autre pour une histoire de nains -
j'angoisse en voyant ça waouh tout le
temps je vois ces news parlait de ses
douze d'achille donc on a peur de horse
on a peur à la salle de sports on a peur
à la piscine juste eu peu coupé mais
c'est un vrai rolex balanciaga ton mais
bien sûr c'est la nouvelle collection à
putanges chambéry qu est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal que même chez moi
quand je rentre chez moi j'ai peur c'est
vrai mais ça c'était avant
on dirait mon truc la mettre à l'eau son
truc j'avoue
je suis chez moi on va dire je suis dans
le salon je commence à m'ennuyer avec un
mec on s'embrouille quoi qu est-ce qu à
la cantine tu critiques chicoine encore
cindy doire la cantine ce week-end en
soirée si paris le pire quand ça parle
sur la cantine mais voilà on en aura le
pacéen le coup de vis du cloud la
cantine donc on est en train de la
cantoche mais j'ai fini le philosophe
quand bon vous l'un au scénario ok ok
fait les mains je suis en train de
rentrer du boulot est là derrière moi
qu'est ce que je vois une silhouette qui
me suit sur la route je me dis emmerdes
qui est rentré chez moi et il se trouve
que mon verrou de cellule est cassé
c'est à dire quand je vais rentrer chez
moi le gars il peut rentrer ces gens un
moulin chez moi à ta bile dans un moulin
non non non ça à la maison mais ces
genres un moulin va-et-vient bon ton
histoire je le suspect que je vois l'on
se rapprocher de plus en plus vite de
plus en plus menaçante je me dis oh
je commence à marcher un peu
public commence à courir et à la longue
elle se met à courir
là je rentre chez moi j'ai cet objet il
est sur le point de me sauver la vie je
mets cet objet sous la porte raconté un
truc juste y en a pour deux jours à la
cantine ça m'a choqué quand il a parlé
de ça parce que je pensais pas qu'on
pouvait en parler aussi vertement le ca
plus le moulin mais que j'ai pas compris
de moulins et voilà ça va après
seulement quelques secondes ils pas
compris c'est le gâteau suis quoi qu'il
en soit j'ai en quelques secondes
barricadé la porte et là qu'est ce que
je peux dire un il était maire pourquoi
tu vas rien faire du tout et grâce à cet
objet je sais que je suis en sécurité
il peut rien m'arriver constitué grâce à
cet objet
contrôlé la course et me
voici le
trio ça va voir j'ai évité de très gros
problèmes grâce à mon objet
est que plus belle ou non j'attends vos
notes quand il ya monsieur cagoulés qui
rentrait là tu l'avais mis
fin j'ai envie de le croire mais j'ai
pas eu la preuve que ça marchait pas
après j'ai pas aimé comment il courait
ces noms l'idée en tant que tel je
trouve ça excellent grève donc
initialement ma note était de 15 hockey
et je me suis dit ce serait quand même
ouf si elle pas un truc qui marche c'est
mieux que toi tu es une clé ou injuste
ouais c'est ça et du coup ma note est
passée astank cinq points c'est pour que
le mec il ne frappe pas quand je sors je
trouve impossible comment 13 sinon au
moins treize 13 parce que je crois en
l'objet et j'aime beaucoup le truc est
super cool merci à travailler sans
explication nul
objets pas dingue mise en scène
incroyable sa manière un doute
je vous remercie pour vos notes et
j'espère surtout que ça sauvera des vies
la clé vers la gauche la prochaine fois
sa frange en 2007
oui bon ça c'est bien aussi
bon les gars je vais pas vous déranger
un nom
vous êtes à la cantine à vous sortez du
moulin vous arrivez à la cantine tac tic
a fait tic a droit à
sa seule bouteille imaginer que c'est du
café
était très fort c'est donc verser mon
café qu'est ce qui peut se passer là tu
peux renverser tout de suite été brûlées
tête
du bouillon ça c'est grave bon au
précieux grains dans une certain ben
swift ni les saadé miettes genre
quelqu'un aurait mis des miettes avant
au même endroit c'est chiant j'ai une
solution c'est le faire si demain je
suis président de république ce possible
cette fois ci propose que chaque élève
quand il entre dans sa cantine et qu'il
s'apprête à faire son souper son
déjeuner sont
plus un besoin pour se développer il est
équipé de cet objet bon
ça stabilise la regarder il ya de l'eau
il ya des miettes que quelqu'un me owen
wah wah enfin l'opinion
non pas nous plaît c'est juste un truc à
temps on va faire scénario on se
rentrent dedans on imagine ce n'est pas
ça
la marche pas
[Musique]
huawei jeux pc
il a vraiment cette fonction-là cet
objet oui alors moi mon cher hugo juste
admirer une dernière fois la force de la
science en moi j'ai décidé de
d'attribuer la note de 15 sur 20 j'adore
me servir des tasses de thé tu sais bien
à ras bord quoi voir le thé au
bord de la chute de l'eau j'aime bien
bouillante j'ai décidé de mettre aussi
un petit plus un ce qui nous amène à
savoir l'origine sur 20 parce que je
trouve que la démonstration était quand
même plein de dextérité va essayer nous
mêmes on arrivait soient ressortis tech
la gravité je suis très grands aussi
rémois c'est pour ça que moi ça marchait
pas dire merci ouais non non non non
j'espère annoncer un vidéo comme moi ça
marchait haut comme trois écoutes hugo
un peu pour les mêmes raisons je t'ai
mis cette note le cese de france 16
annoncés non je me trouvais ça un modèle
de scouts je t'ai mis 14 passes et un
petit gag dans la vidéo je vous
l'écrivais xvii donc oui ça faisait 16
en chiffres romains je voulais faire
genre nancy j'ai écrit xbee c'était la
petite blague absurdes comme ça j'ai un
petit univers toi aussi tu as mis 14
c'est vraiment sur ta petite planète je
suis sur ma petite planète chérie 14
bravo
c'est la fin de cette vidéo vous pouvez
constater la taille de hugo on est en
full rp la douloureuse et qui parle mais
si on joue et des
résultats des comptes moyenne générale
bon je vais être honnête on a en a pas
on a oublié de tous mais ça s'affiche à
l'écran bravo aux gagnants ont
placé les notes du jury maintenant à
vous de voter dans les commentaires qui
a gagné selon vous ce concours du
meilleur objet il faut pas se baser que
sur des objets se faisait surtout la
prestation la fonction d'objet la
manière biais pas que j'ai mis un
costume j'ai passé un bon moment et puis
moi système cheb mami est excellent et
je propose qu'on finisse la vidéo avec
des mains sur les genoux comme on l'a
oui c'est ma récompense et
je vais vous laisser rentrer chez vous
on a à notre souper souple et tout à
l'heure ça fait trois arrêts parle d'un
souper j'en veux plus vous allez manger
quoi la soul la soupe
allez bonne appétit
[Musique]